thing will turn off you
mean
great so um
hello and uh it's a a great pleasure for
me to uh be able to give you uh to talk
to you today about stem
cells um this I have to confess is a a
unique experience for me
uh actually giving a lecture where I
can't see the audience where I'm
actually talking into uh talking into
our
camera um can't see the
response but uh this is probably a
unique experience for you to let's let's
give this a shot so um for the next
hour uh you can see the title I'm going
to be talking about stem cells but I'm
going to be giving it uh kind of a a bit
of a unique spin maybe a little bit
different than you're used to hearing
about it what I'm going to do is remind
you throughout the entire talk that even
if you're interested in the
translational value of stem
cells what you really are are
developmental biologist and that stem
cells are fundamentally part of
Developmental
biology um
and what you'll also see is that this
guide this kind of
bias will even permeate the way that I
think about using stem cells in
cell-based
therapies
um
so this also leads into an
aspect that probably is on the mind of
many people in the audience
which
is I enjoy the science uh I love the
biology but when can I actually use this
to treat a
patient and this has kind of been in the
background of the stem cell field from
the earliest days of the spem
cell um even before we understood the
complexities and it's the complexities
I'm going to spend the hour talking
about when is it appropriate to attempt
a therapy in the phase of imperfect and
incomplete knowledge recognizing that we
will never have complete knowledge and
that our knowledge will always be
dynamic and changing it will always be
imperfect these are kind of my guiding
principles and they've been my guiding
principles from the very beginning of
the field when do you try something new
in St cells and your Journal of Medicine
are something new I guess I would say is
of course when standard of care is not
optimal of course when it's safe of
course when what you do is not going to
deply a patient of better proven options
but probably what we have here is when
what you want to do makes absolute
biologic sense because it Mak sense in
terms of our known
biology of the cell and our known
biology of the disease where the gaps
exist recognizing that these are
constantly movings so when I talk this
is going to be guiding a lot of the way
I present some of these data which means
that if you want to put this into
biotech terms that one needs to know
mechanism of action that becomes very
important that's a guiding princip one
also has to be very secure in the proof
of concept so I'm going to be spending a
lot of time talking about that from the
vantage point of the stencil and then of
course stacle competitiveness means that
what you want to offer still is better
and safer and ideally maybe even less
expensive and less harmful and less
painful and less invasive than what
already exists in so the themes that I'm
going to be covered that I'm going to
cover over the hour
are uh the even if you lose contact and
you don't listen to another word that I
say these I think will be the important
take-home messages that I want to leave
with
you and that's to reiterate the way I
started stem cells are the building
blocks of the body and of each organ of
the body they are ultimately part of
fundamental developmental programs their
job is to put an organ or a system
together that's organogenesis and then
to maintain that organ's function all
throughout life even in the face of
pertubations that's why nature puts stem
cells there and that is what we need to
understand when we want to use stem
cells
therapeutically what we have to realize
is that we're harnessing these programs
to and trying to invoke them or reinvoke
them we can't go to at Cross purposes to
what their biology is meant to be but it
does open up all kinds of possibilities
think of it as rebooting the computer or
recing the
law now for the cells to do
this they engage in an enormous amount
of cross talking complexity we tend to
think of stem cells as purely these the
these these cells that are going to do
cell replacement kind of swap them in
swap them out the way you change a
carburetor in a car but cell replacement
is just one of the mechanisms by which
nature puts St stem cells there
toachieve balance in a dise equilibrated
system they do many many other things
they change the meu they Shack own cells
they restore normal cellular metabolism
and in some respects that may actually
be lower handing more attainable than
cell
replacement um more tractable and and in
the end maybe even more important not
that not going to get to cell
replacement but as you'll see that we
may be able to make an impact taking
advantage of what may even be more
important parts of the fundamental
biology then I won't have time to get to
this but of course our whole area of
regenerative medicine is the notion of
taking the stem cells growing them in a
dish and discovering what the mechanism
what the drug Target might be for a
particular disease and then of course
finding the drug
that may actually change that so it's
not the cell that goes into the patient
but it's the drug discovered from the
cell that goes into the patient I won't
have time to get into that but I think
that's an important aspect to to try to
remember now how did I personally get
into the stem cell field myself well I
think this is also going to be important
for any clinicians in the audience
um I started getting into the stem cell
field before it was called the stem cell
field and and this is an example of what
we like to call not bench to bedside but
bedside to bench this is a picture of a
CT scan of a baby that I took care of
I'm a pediatrician and particularly a
pediatric neurologist and
neonatologist and longer ago than I
would care to admit I took care of this
baby who had a stroke the baby went on
to get completely better and I went to
my professors my attendance and I said
how could this possibly be this there
was no MRI these are before the days of
MRIs and I I said how could this
possibly be How could a baby have a
stroke like this and then after seeing
the baby at at about a year of age the
baby got complet was completely better
they said well well kids do that kind of
stuff but I wondered how did they do
that what was the essence of this kind
of plasticity because if we could
understand it then maybe we could
harness it and do it in situations where
this does
not back to the bed to the bench from
the bedside to the bench and found that
contrary to what had been the case the
prevailing Dogma for the nervous system
and for other parts of the body the left
hand model a very deterministic model
they found that there were actually
cells like the yellow cell on the right
that could give rise to many different
cell types much later in development
than you would ever imagine well these
yellow cells are cells that came to be
called stem cells and they started
opening up the whole notion that the
body was more plastic than we ever
imagined including rigid organs like the
nervous system that cells existed that
perhaps could be extracted expanded and
then put back that would recapitulate
this kind of natural kind of plasticity
so those were cells before the Advent of
the stem cell field now as you know we
do have a very Vibrance St up Feld and I
would like to say that even though
sometimes the political debate forces us
to pigeonhole various kinds of stem
cells that's not actually the way nature
works that uh in fact there's a
Continuum a Continuum from cells let's
say that exist in the Inner Cell Mass
that we now call embryonic stem cells to
cells in the fetus that are now going to
give rise to all the various cells of
the body and into
adultery now the political debate has
forced us to talk about embryonic stem
cells and adult stem cells but what all
of us are really doing are focusing on
what the cells are doing right here
during development if you're starting on
the extreme left with the plasis you're
trying to teach yourself that it's meant
to be living in the fetus giving rise to
the equil if you're on the extreme
right um you're trying to fool yourself
into thinking that it's living in the
fetus giving rise to these various organ
systems and it's these kind of signals
that we want to recapitulate now we also
learn that this continuity this
Continuum not only goes from left to
right
that now also goes from right to left
because we now have the ability to take
cells at the extreme right and do
various kinds of
reprogramming it it
simply and it can be your favorite way
of doing this you can take a cell and
push it back into developmental time so
it acts as if it's still living in the
blastic and still can give rise to the
various kinds of cell types that that
that you see here now these of course
are called induced Florin
SKS
now these kind of cells and I I guess
you can't see the movies but they can
give rise to all of these various kinds
of cell types
and you can
get uh trying to play this now beating
cardiomyocytes that would be slide uh I
guess it would be slide number one or
video number one Tracy you can sort of
see Beating Heart cells that one can
actually do a kind of a stem cell EKG
with blood
vessels maybe maybe I won't use too many
videos it looks like it's oens up a
little bit it would be uh video number
two
okay so what I want to
do do I have the slide down again
okay
so before we start talking about using
the cells for
transplantation I do want to make a bit
of a nod to the fact that this is
still the importance of stem cells still
is most profound in teaching us about
embryogenesis organogenesis and then the
various homeostasis homeostasis
preserving mechanisms that exist in the
stem cell that again we want that we
want to harness so again in this lecture
I'll be talking about the top what we're
going to be doing in Beaver perhaps if I
don't screw up too badly I'll be invited
back to give a second lecture where
later on I can talk about using the stem
cells in vitro to model diseases and
model
processes however even if we want to
talk about I think it's important to
understand what the logic is what the
program is that the stem cell is
starting to to carry out and let's go
back here as you can
see let's talk about one of the very
first programs and that's this Inner
Cell mass or the the the epiblast
deciding that it wants to First give
rise to a nervous system and this was a
question that Ilia singet in the lab
wanted to do he wanted to see whether in
fact he could actually start getting
noral to closure in a dish the formation
of the noral tube than the closure the
earliest stages of
neurogenesis um and in fact he was able
to do that as you can say here able to
get very nice noral tubes in in a
dish
but he was able to do it by
recapitulating development and he was
able to find that if he used the right
formula that the that the epiblast
actually uses to give Neal food he could
very very quickly get pure neural stem
cells in a dish particularly if you used
small molecules to close off all the
other fate options prevent them from
doing giving rise to endoderm or
mesoderm or even staying very poent so
can could be give rise to early neural
stem cells and then Cascade his way to
getting the various kinds of more mature
Neal stem
cells this is an example of pure neurons
and the default pathway interestingly is
to give rise to neurons that are
interneurons gabic or dramaturgic living
in the dorsal core brain and the cortex
now that doesn't mean that one can't
give rise to other kinds of cells but
there you actually need to give them
very very specific instruction tell them
you need to be ventral you give Sonic
you need to be in the vental Meson so
you give it fgfa or you inhibit gsp3
beta if you want to get dopamine or or
if you want to to get
motor now once you have this there is
this notion of being able to get stem
cell to to get this the cells particular
if you took these cells from a patient
he he had a
disease you could have cortical neurons
for example that have autism that have
re or that have Alzheimer disase now
this is not a new notion in the early
days we were able to go to diseased
fuses after after miscarriages or even
to postmortem tissue in adults pull out
the neural stem cells and say well we
have a neural stem cell that has
Alzheimer's disease so this notion of
modeling diseases in a dish is not new
with the Advent of the embryonic stem
cell field we could go to infertility
clinics where they were doing
preimplantation genetic diagnosis and
there would be a blasticus that had a
disease that could not be implanted that
would be discarded from now we could
make embryonic them cells turn them into
neurons just the way I showed you that
these would be neurons that had
otherwise a lethal disease for us to
study but again what we would love to do
is to be able to get to cells that are
that do not involve the the death of the
donor even for those kind of cells that
are formally kind of inaccessible and
that's where these induced chloric poent
stencils these IPS CS became
particularly Ed being able to get
difficult to obtain cells from a living
patient now I extol the virtue of
getting pure stem cells uh pure lineages
in a dish now
everybody could say and again this is
going to come up when we're talking
about trying to repair the nervous
system that that's not really the way
the nervous system is built in fact
that's not the way any organ the
vertebra body primer bu it's not just
pure cells it's pure lineage it's
lineages interacting with each other so
every medical student will tell you that
every organ every limb every extremity
is vein artery nerves
the vascul comes from the mes the
nervous system comes from the epid but
nevertheless you get the embrionic organ
you get the fetal organ native organ
your adult
organ and everything is completely
coordinated well that must be another
kind of system where lineages cross talk
to each other so that there's constant
co- pattern and that was something that
Jeff linquist and set ASO in our lab in
collaboration with uh David cherish they
were joint postto between the two of us
wanted to
explore and I won't play this video
again but you could see that we could
get vasculature very very
nicely but at the exact same time as we
were getting vasculature we also were
able to get nervous system and I would
like to play this video If You Could I
guess this video would be video number
three
I'm not sure I guess you have to play
that
Trac is
that could you keep playing it I think
it's on a
loop
is the video
playing all right well this is a m we
better go
on what you would see is that the two
line AG is just follow each other like
trains on a tram trun they just
completely c-n each other vasculature
neural that's a program and that if you
uh the interesting thing is what
initially sets the neurovascular pattern
is not the central nervous system not
coming from the neural tube but actually
coming from the neural crest once that
happens and what you can see here is the
blue cells are smooth muscle the green
cells are neuroc Crest becoming
autonomic nervous system the red cells
are vascular indial cells and they
together emerge simultaneously cross
talk to each other and if you get rid of
any one of them the differentiation the
emergence of patterns of all of them
completely fall apart it's an oblate
cross talk be between them after that
pattern is set and I guess we need to go
to the next video please I guess this
will be video number
four but maybe that's you can
see that
then why why why don't we just skiing uh
some of the other videos that will have
to play for longer but this central
nervous system in blue then comes out
and joins the parade then joins a
pattern that had previously been
established between the neural press and
the autonomic n system but it's an
obligate cross talk that needs to take
place so let's say however this is all
Arcane stuff and you really don't care
so much about this fundamental biology
what you really want to do is be this
guy drilling into a head of somebody
just let's get cut to the Chase and
let's start fixing things I would make
the argument that even then what you are
is a developmental a translational
developmental
biologist and what you need to know is
to be able to harness these programs and
it really doesn't matter let's use the
nervous system as an example and the
neural stem cell as an example doesn't
really matter how you get to become a
neural stem cell whether you want to do
it in es CS IPS CS fetal tissue or even
from the adult you're going to get a
neural stem cell and it's still going to
be the same fundamental biology that you
need to understand and that is this
notion that when you take a Sten Cil and
you put it into a pathologic post
there's a dynamic and both elements
change the stem cell changes the host
changes and it changes in response to
these various arrows and it's these
various arrows that you that one needs
to begin to understand and to identify
so let's start
understanding what these arrows
are
sorry that um the arrows will play out
fundamental developmental program that
are inherently in place to to to
compensate for these
pertubations so what would be the first
arrow that one would look at let's look
at this very top Arrow as you can see
over here it's the notion that the host
tells the neural stem cell a come hither
kind of signal if there's pathology what
we were able to
observe is that the stem cell seemed to
gravitate where to where there was
pathology now what was interesting is
that it did it in a whole series of
kinds of pathologic situations and
initially this was very perturbing it
happened in lemia and Trauma and tumors
neural
degeneration now all of these had a
different ideology a different temper so
we had to figure out what was it that
they all had in common the common
denominator to all of them was an
inflammatory signature now we had always
been taught that inflammation is bad and
it is bad but it's it's kind of Jus face
it also has another side to it and in
fact that's what we called this paper
inflammation's other side and what we
realized is that it was the inflammation
that the stem cell was keeing into and
the the Prototype that we used at the
time was sdf1 Alpha as the inflammatory
chemine and
cxcr4 as the
prototypical uh a prototypical receptor
what this shows is that after an infar
on this top there was a huge Rec
crescence of STL Point Alpha and that's
what the human neural stem cells would
home to on the intact side not at all
and the cells would do it in a onetoone
correspondence what was expressing sdf1
Alpha was reactive asites and inflame
the vascul so it made an enormous amount
of sense now if we wanted to harness
that we couldn't just take the pure stf1
alha what you because you really would
actually create more harm than good but
what you could do is optimize The
Binding and minimize the signaling and
that's what we've done to actually make
a peptide based on sdf1 Alpha that
exacerbates and that allows homing to
come under our control now get to that
in another way now what else could the
host be telling the stem cell it may
also be telling them that of all the
things you can become we want you to
become this particular Cel and that's
driven by the host so here are all the
various cell types that one might see
all venoc Sites neurons and Asos sites
and we wonder if we went to a situation
where neurons were missing would the
stem cell shift to become that missing
kind of neuron
now the answer is complex so the answer
was yes but it wasn't wrong it was just
naive what Jeff Maus and I did was go to
a very artificial situation take Tak
advantage of a very clever model that
Jeff developed in which he was able to
as you can see over here one small part
of the adult Maman cortex that one
little part of the brain where there
shouldn't be neurogenesis he developed
the method of targeting apoptosis of
paramal
neurons if we took the neural stem cells
and just in that one particular box put
them there not outside the box there
they came Lees which was very
appropriate that inside the Box they
would give rise to parameter nurs and
some of these paramal neurons would
actually send processes across to the
other side as you can see from this
tract Trace well that seemed cool and it
establish the situation that where
there's injury even in the adult one can
start seeing uh new neurona genesis the
cues kind of get
recapitulated when where it was naive
was the fact that it was a very
artificial situation and that um that
most diseases are not well that was
neurons we wondered could we do the
exact same thing with gells so we went
to a situation where G cells were
actually going to be degenerated there
was a mouse and I guess we will need the
movie uh movie for this called uh the
shiver Mouse
he could you play this movie
please the amount of shiver is
dramatically reduced and we go we'll go
back to the
slides I think you can see this is the
that panel C is the amount of shiver the
whole body Tremor of an animal not
treated D is the amount of tremor that
was eliminated it happened because the
alad dendrites were uh becoming the
dysfunctional replacing in that
particular case the dysfun
allig and we've been able to now go to
some other models the blue here
represents cells in a mouse model of a
Luca distri in a trabas disease called
the twitcher mouse where you can see
that the blue cells have distributed
themselves throughout the neural axis
and where there normally are no aladen
sites are now giving rise to aladen
sites these blue are represent a whole
Halo of Co axons that are being
melinated as you can see over here this
is all donor derived M um with very nice
major densities there now both of these
models they were encouraging in the mid
90s but it was
naive the the targeted apoptotic model
doesn't recapitulate itself in nature
that kind of pure
apoptosis the shiver Mouse has no Cate
in human disease most diseases are very
complex it's not a single cell it's not
a single pathologic process and we
learned that lesson when we started
actually going to a stroke like lusion
as you can see that
the and this is a study that was done by
kopen Park and a neonatologist who
wanted to look at a stroke like lesion
in the road the arrowhead above points
to very devastating lesion from hypo
toxic schic injury what park did is he
took the cells as you can see on the
bottom frame and put them down you know
into the left and they would move from
the implantation in the left all the way
over migrating across kishur and
kosum to the place where the impact was
all throughout the all throughout the
the the cere if you put the cells
directly in there as you can see in this
next slide they completely filled out
and there's a higher power view shown
towards the
right if he looked at what the cells
were becoming there he saw as you can
see in the other panel that they became
you know they certainly became neurons
I'm going to see whether I can do any
kind of pointing
um I guess I
can't
let's let's let's forget
the so they became
neurons that also send processes across
to the other side but he saw something
else that was also exceedingly
interesting you saw that they were
becoming alenes sites as you can see in
that left panel and if you started doing
the math he was able to show not only
were the cells becoming new neurons but
they were becoming new aladen sites new
asites even new neural stensils in other
words what what the Seno was doing was
trying to recapitulate the entire
environment and often what I liked it
knew that we didn't just need neurons
that's not what es schia is it knew we
needed to give rise to neurons but it
also needed to give rise to the alend
sites and to the asites and I often like
to say that even the dumbest stem cell
is
smarter than the smartest neurologist it
knew that this is what we need to
recapitulate and it had programs that
would start that would start doing
that so there had to be a degree of
cross talk between these cells for this
kind of thing to happen and the cross
talk was the stem cells talking to each
other giving rise to a division of labor
so this is a schematic of one of the
ways that we were able to that we've
kind of teased out this summarizes a
whole lot of data the neural stem cell
is cycling it looks as if it does give
rise to a uh to either by stochastic
either stochastically or by instruction
or by design it gives rise to a neuron
the neuron then sends out signals to its
host to to its sister and brother cells
that even if they wanted to become a
neuron they are actively inhibited from
becoming neurons they become non neurons
or gells that
then and a lot of the signaling can be
through uh dmps it can be through match
Delta it can even be through codes in
the neuronal membrane but now the Glo
cell will feed back onto the neuron the
neuron GRS receptor to it now gdnf is
just one example that I'm going to be
coming back to a lot of a whole series
of these kind of factors that are
chaperoned by the G that that are
chaperoned that serve as a chaperon by
the GL cells to the neurons the neuron
goes a receptor to now this makes an
enormous amount of sense it's a self
assembling mechanism where the non-
neural cells coming from the neural stem
cell from the the same conone will
shaone and protect now if you take that
biology and you do a transplant into an
abnormal host well then the host becomes
the fortunate
beneficiary
um fortunate beneficiary of this kind of
process now the factors are stimulus
appropriate they Quant the pulson but
now the host has benefited
this is called the chapone effect it's
mediated by the P3 kyes path and it's so
important because I would venture to say
with very few
exceptions every therapeutic benefit to
date that we have
seen um has actually not been through
cell replacement but through the shapo
effect and in fact even if you replace
neurons it's a good thing to also
replace or at least have them shaper
by um have them shap by the
gells
um so once that happens because of that
cross talk now you have the stem cell
talking back to the host and bathing the
host in a whole series of various
diffusible factors now if you take the
stem cell and you stick it into the
ventricles the ventricles are lined by a
germinal Zone the germinal zone is the
home of the stem cells and you place
them in there and they will distribute
themselves throughout the
brain turny quick but they will move out
there because that's really what they're
normally meant to do just stup it
themselves throughout the brain
integrate in a seamless fashion fashion
in the substance of the brain and one
could could start uh
imagining that um that what about if
this was something not just a gene that
gave a color but something that you
cared about that could actually bring in
a bioactive molecule uh in a troan hor
fashion what kind of diseases would this
be pertinent to well it would be
pertinent to this whole class of lysomal
stor diseases is rare diseases but in
the aggregate fairly common and affect
the Pediatric Group because all of these
kids miss within their brains an enzyme
which is a normal housekeeping Gene for
the stem cell that now if the stem cell
is distributed throughout the brain just
cranks it out and cross corrects these
kind of cells almost like a bone marrow
transplant to the
brain so losal enzymes could be one of
the things and and in fact the the use
of St stem cells for these diseases back
in the early 90s turned out as you can
see in this paper to be the very first
therapeutic use of a solid organ
nonatopic stem cell again tapping into
its normal fundamental biology and Gene
F lead did this kind of paper this is
now some later work but you can see in
the upper left hand corner the cells
distributed themselves throughout the
brain and as a result of restoring in
this particular ular case hexosaminidase
b could forestall the onset of disease
preserve M function and significantly
prolong light not because it was
replaced in cells but because it
replaced through its normal housekeeping
function missing
enzymes the cells also have a direct
anti-inflammatory effect here's an
example of the cells actually
diminishing directly activated micosis
or actively inhibiting the amount of
inflammatory cyto and what we're
starting to learn is every disease every
neurod degenerative disease every injury
really has an inflammatory signature to
it and this simply summarizes uh the
whole host of mechanisms by which the
neural stem cells other than cell
replacement where there was some degree
of it were able to kind of complement
and make an impact on this type of neur
generative
disease the cells also have a direct ner
protective event uh action antiscarring
mobilize endogenous stem cells and make
those cells send NE promote neide
out grow have even an effect on the host
vascular now here's an example of of
where all of that kind of uh kind of
observations come together a little bit
not because I I I don't want to slow
things down I I'll just describe this
and not use not use the arrow but if you
look at the middle you know the middle
panel you can see all kinds of green
that's scarl it's gfap but it looks as
if the scarring comes to a halt after
this infarction in something that almost
looks like the map of green well if you
like to do jiga puzzles you can look up
a little bit and you can see on the top
panel there's red that red area those
are human noal stem cells and it almost
looks as if that would fit into where
the scaring to stop and the merged image
on the bottom shows in fact that where
the neural stem cells are the scarring
stops and now what used to be formerly a
no man Zone a no man's land is an area
that allows now as you can see in the
bottom panel on the right allows poost
cells to send out
processes that can navigate through an
area that formerly was excluded from
them simply because the scarring had
been
inhibited what's another action well if
you look at the bottom pole at the
bottom panel you can see the blue arroe
head is pointing to fibers crossing the
cortex which are completely fine there's
nothing wrong with that whatsoever
that's exactly the way it should be but
if you go to the top panel and you can
see this is an area of the brain in the
extreme left hand part that was infared
but it was infared and now invested with
Neal stem cells and you can see that now
the fibers that normally should just be
you know kind of perpendicular now are
rather giving rise to these long
delicate Aran fibers that are bending
and starting to send fibers in to this
area that was damaged but now trying to
join the
parade participating as you can see in
this next slide in part of the neural
network and not only doing that but
inviting this new neural network this
new parena to be vascularized as you can
see in panel D that the hour was
pointing to them now formally now taking
all of these processes together as you
can see in a and area that would have
enormous amount of parthal loss now
seems to have a reconstitution of that
par now is this beautiful textbook
parang absolutely not in fact it's a bit
of a mess it doesn't have this beautiful
lamination but is it safe that the stem
cell and the host are starting to talk
to each other in a way that tries to
reconstruct the milu I think that is
what it says and even though it wasn't
pretty this animal actually did better
so again tapping into a fundamental
process we learn this from hypoxic
asemic injury from stroke like leion can
we apply it to spinal cord injury well
Ted Tang decided that he was going to
look at this particular process and he
did a whole huge Hemi resection and what
he wanted to do was see whether he could
stem cells simp put on a staffle and
Bridge this huge gap and what I want to
do is show you the data first the video
could you could you bring that up please
Tracy this becomes important this this
actually is a very important
video and we're going to show you data
that first
we
well this we found to be really pretty
exciting um let's move to the next and
of of course we thought well this is
great like to put a plant to Stockholm
stem cells are the greatest thing since
Cann beer do it do I need to move this
to get
next so we figured we need to figure out
what was going
on well we simply looked at the
histology and we saw all this green
staining this is great these are neural
fibers going through the epis when we
stain to see who was giving rise to the
neural fibers that's what the
surprise the red cells are our cells
they are not the ones giving rise to the
neural fibers in fact all these neural
fibers Bridging the injury were coming
from the host not the stem cells but yet
they were having the impact that you saw
which again
made us recognize the power in fact it
helped us understand what the shapon
effect actually was what the stem cells
were doing here again is this the
epicenter Circle the green represents
the scarring where the stem cells are
the scarring stopped and now it was the
host fibers that were allowed to be able
to now go through the Cent that it's not
pretty it's a little bit ratty but it
was sufficient with both motar and
sensory sufficient to help restore some
of the function now here you can see the
red cells those are the human neur stem
cells the green cells are host neurons
the green cells are not becoming the
neurons but now because they're
expressing a whole host of Tropic
factors the animal's own neurop fibers
are forsing through
them if they're there as you can see in
this Suri the searings seems to be
reduced in size now does that mean that
we can't get a little bit of extension
points for example we know that this has
to be multifaceted but can we get little
Bridges from the neurons from the neural
stem cells as illustrated by this this
AR well I think we can but in a muted
fashion it can also help the situation
these are examples of donor derived
bridging Ms as we can see
now are those playing any kind of role
here's the spinal cord of a rat and if
they are playing any kind of a role if
we put a track Tracer down below as you
can see over
here and track blue where that arror is
it should go up the axon and turn that
cell blue it's really sending a fiber
down and in fact that seems to be what
happens so some of the cells not all of
the cells as you can see there the Red
Cell that's a donor Drive cell it shows
that it's a human neuron and of those
three cells that one's blue because of
the cent of fiber down down there so we
are getting some cells that are Bridging
the Gap like that now what they're doing
is Bridging the Gap and what we think
they're doing is invoking
intraspinal circuitry so another way of
invoking circuitry that can mediate some
of movement that don't involve higher
centes but if you take the protection
you take the anti-scarring and the
proangiogenesis and invoking these
various kinds of uh of intraspinal
segments taking it together so now you
start getting some improved function the
kind of function that I was able to to
to show you before over there here this
is motor evoke potentials it's not
beautiful it's not perfect
a uh L numo one shows motor evoke
potentials l numo two shows sensory
evoke
potentials each one a is what you would
normally see C is what happens without
any kind of intervention p is asked
after intervention so it's not normal
but it looks to be significantly better
than than what you would see in
C and the BBB scale seems to be better
it's a combination of of the stem cell
being the orchestra leader of trying to
mediate all the various kinds of action
that are going to be necessary for
spinal cred inur what we're able to show
in fact is that the the same kind of
thing can be extended to even large
animals to large primals same kind of
process the cells and the scaffold shown
over there diminishing the amount of
neurod degeneration as you can see with
the silver stting on the left side
decreasing the amount of inflammation as
you can see on the right side
um so that is the scaffold the stem
cells with the asteris showing decrease
degeneration and on the right side with
decreased
information so in the interest of time
I'm not going to go through this uh I
think you'll be able to access the list
of all the various kinds of actions the
multiple mechanisms that are required
that underly
recovery following spinal with injury
media
by and you're going to start seeing that
I'm recapitulating the scam over and
over again in Parkinson's disease same
type of thing homeostatic effects
multimo from Human neural stem cells
multiple actions Parkinson's disease as
you can see there can be modeled by
lesioning a monkey with mptp the neural
stem cells there are implanted into the
nbra into the
striatum and what you could see is that
in the in the top bre that the amount of
parkinsonian symptoms were reduced
compared to a shame control not to
normal but dramatically reduced now how
did that happen again through multiple
mechanisms some of the cells did become
dopaminergic as you can see here but not
enough of them to account for with
function maybe only about
3% so it was there but that's not a was
responsible for the recovery what was
responsible for the recovery was
preservation of the host nigr strial
pathway the red cells here are the donor
cells they're not becoming the th
positive cells those are the animals own
th positive cells that normally would
have died that are not and now what you
can see in this slide is that the donor
cells are right next cheek by Jou with
the donor with the host th positive
cells making
gbnf causing diminished inflammation
preserving the path these are examples
of rescue post dop energic nor would be
kind of nice here's an example of a
preserved nigos Jal pathway these are
the functions so it wasn't recreating
this pathway but it was preserving the
pathway that existed there as you can
see
and then for some other reason for a
mechanism that we actually do not
understand one can start seeing that
there was diminished alos nucle again we
don't know the mechanism but the stem
cell will somehow also restoring normal
metabolism to the cell allowing this
kind of
thing to to to to happen so again
multiple
mechanisms which now brings us to a very
recent result to to ALS now it used to
be thought that ALS was a simple
disease um we're starting to know now
that it's not a simple disease when we
started looking at this disease we
thought it was going to be just like the
experiment that Jeff mackas and I did
ALS is motor neurons look the experiment
that Jeff and I did with parabal neurons
just being knocked out should be the
same just moving down to the well
what we learned is as many of you in the
audience know ALS is exceedingly complex
it's many different kinds of pathologies
and you're not meant to look at this
except that this is Don Cleveland's way
of saying look how many things are going
on so now we wondered in fact could the
various mechanisms that we're starting
to learn the stem cell was playing out
be matched to the many pathologic
mechanisms that are playing out uh in in
ALS and the fact that we were able to
publish this paper about a year ago
shows that that seemed to work so here
is where we do need hopefully you can
play this video um are you able to play
this video
Tracy
not only should he not be able to do
that he actually should not even even be
alive this he's walking the rad to Rod
at over 200 days of age and most of
these ALS M1 Mouse die at 90 to
120s but yet as a
result of the intervention and the
intervention was taking the nor stem
cells and going into multiple cardinal
for alal axd delayed dis disease onet
slow disease progression improve
performance but now why was it able to
do that well here's an example of how we
transplanted the animal and here's an
example of not only a delay in motor
function but as you can see in this
Captain M curves that a subset of the
animals about a qu of the animals
reliably had very prolonged survival
some to almost a year and a half why was
that happening well if you look in panel
B you can see some of the cells did
become motor neurons but that was not
what was doing it those motor neurons
that we saw were not mature they were
not sending processes out the vental
horn um they did not have mature markers
so even though we saw some of them these
those could not be a responsible for
what we were seeing but inevitably as
you look at higher power you can see
that the few cells that were becoming
motor neurons even immature motor
neurons were surrounded by a huge number
of cells that were clearly not so we
started looking at those and those cells
that were not becoming neurons but
surrounding both our donor Drive neurons
and the host motor neurons were cring
out a huge amount of
gdnf and as a result as you can see and
they were preserving the host motor
beyond the critical threshold of
10% and as you can see in O the motor
neurons that were preserved had good
were making good intense intact
functional neuromuscular Junctions P
shows on the top that if we went to the
cervical region to the respiratory drive
Center we were preserving their motor
function and preserving their
respiratory function the patients as
well as the mice die a respiratory death
and we're allowing respiratory function
to be
preserved so early on had we been trying
to look for a release or a bioassay we
would have taken the stem cells put it
let's say in a spinal cord slice seen
that they were giving neurons and we
would have said oh yeah the cells are
great now our release criteria is not
what we do is take a spinal C slice take
the blue stem cells put it out there and
we look and quantify neite Al because
then we know as you can see in the
actual data and then in the schematic in
a quantifiable way we are having cells
and are going to effectively create
neurotropic factors that can do this now
as you can see in r one it has to do
this without the N
axis
um it's again its action is not changing
this
genetic the amount of mutations in this
animal so it's it's it's the
manifestation which suggests that even
though we're using a mouse model that
models familiar
ALS maybe if we're getting to to the
output to to the functional
manifestation this can also be applied
to
sporadics what's another mechanism now
if you look in four B shows a lot of uh
kind of a lot of
astrogliosis a in ROM four shows a
diminished amount initially we thought
well what we're just doing is just
decreasing some inflammation not that
that's trivial but we actually as we
started learning more about ALS we
started also realizing that we're having
another very powerful mechanism anybody
who studied ALS now recognize and this
is shown in this gra graph in uh in the
upper the upper bars that asites are one
of the toxic mediat in
ALS and what we saw if we looked the
natural history in this mouse was that
curving red was rampant
asopos and the more rampid the astop
aleosis the more virulent was the
disease
process what we were doing in fact was
having another action we were with our
exogenous SK cells we were changing the
fate of the host neural stem cells and
inhibiting the host neural stem cells
from making what we know are toxic
asides and it's the asdes that are
meeting some of the S we are inhibiting
the hostal stem cells from making toxic
asites we're also then replacing them
without own gentler Kindler more
protective asites and we're also giving
rise to protective gray model
aladen so another mechanism then as you
can see in r five we were diminishing
inflammation activated
micosis of the M neurons that we were
preserving we were diminishing the
amount of nerve fiill
TS as you can see over there so again
multiple mechanisms and in the interest
of time I won't Lisk them but the stem
cell with almost a onetoone
correspondence it's multiple mechanisms
against the multiple mechanisms that you
were seeing as a manifestation of ARS
now this becomes a regulatory nightmare
because now you've got to give a cell
that you want migratory that does many
things that can give rise to many
different kinds of
cell that's the biology that you the
harness and the regulatory agencies are
going to have to come and recognize that
now it's not just a fusible prop there's
also some some self self there's another
mechanism that we discovered Again by
accident and that's that the stem cell
on the host will actually make sell cell
Conta establish Gap Junctions and all of
you know that Gap Junctions are and
that's what we Illustrated here again a
surpris the Gap Junctions are these
pores through which molecules of a
particular size can move they're not
just molecules also it can be
nucleotides it can be mic RNA it can be
many different things we don't know
what's going through there but we know
that it's important again we discovered
this by
accident this is a mouse mutant that has
an abnormal
cerebell I don't in the interest of time
I'm not going to go through what this
what's wrong with the cerebel
except that this animal called the
nervous animal loses its pingi nerves
the pingi layer as you can see in the
top is this beautiful it almost looks
like a pearl
necklace this one cell well in this
animal the pearl necklace as you can see
in the bottom the bottom panel seems to
disappear by early
adul if you take a neural stem cell and
you implant it after the disease has
manifest itself
nothing happens you don't change the
course at all however if you implant the
stencil on the day of birth the disease
manifest so there's another another
lesson there as to how use S thy now you
see something interesting the pearl
necklace exists the pingi cell layer is
preserved if we look to see what was
constituting this P neuron and I think
you know where I'm going with this it
was not in any way oh oops I guess that
slide didn't
play oh minut that slide didn't that
slide didn't come up oh that's is too
bad what you would have seen and I guess
I can show it over here is that the stem
cell here in green is completely
completely
surrounding the host kingi neuron making
cell self compact decorating it with
these white dots which represent the
formation of Gap Junctions if you block
the formation of Gap Junctions you
completely lose that res your that
happens in the nervous animal now I'm
showing you an example of it happening
in other kinds of heni cell degeneration
this is different mechanism the only
thing it has in common is pingi cells
dying and This Is Spinal cerebella
atropy type
one now what are the Gap Junctions doing
we don't know in this very rare muttin
what it was doing is an interesting kind
of gene therapy that animal is
characterized as you can see in this
parabola by having too high a level of
TPA not TPA the way you know it for
stroke but TPA as the Upstream factor of
signal
transduction and what the stem cell
somehow is doing is pushing it back as
you can see in this arrow to the Sak
spot where viability of the of the peni
neuron is its peak the peak of the parab
so it's a different kind of gene therapy
which is also another take- home lesson
not putting in a gene but re-regulating
the animal's own genetic function maybe
that's what that's what the Gap
Junctions are for re regulating
intracellular metabolism so here's the
schematic here the stem cell
actually influencing the amount of
expression of TPA and then the
downstream effectors are improved better
NE Factor handling better mitochondrial
function but it's not just uh and then
making the whole thing more balanced so
it's and it's not just in these kind of
inherited rare diseases this is an
example of exactly the same thing
happening via that Junctions in in
spinal
so what are the many things now that the
stem cell is doing it summarized here
cross talk and the shaone effect which
means uh that the stem cells are nothing
cell replacement but engaging in the
cross talkop it is going to completely
reorder the
M now can we actually change the
endogenous
dispens well there's an example of doing
that and and again there's both a
positive and a negative lesson that that
that's acquired from that and again as
you can see a lot of what we're learning
are the kind of lessons that you learn
by either being really lucky or making a
mistake and then reinterpret so the
notion would
be could we use the stem cell to deliver
a trans Gene that's going to affect the
hope stem cell so the stem cell here is
just a delivery and I'll get to that in
a second now we wonder NT3 is known to
take stem cells and make them more Neons
could we get more Neons so we thought
well let's make the neural stem cell
Express lots of
NT3 and what would happen is it would
spill out into the mil it would feed
back onto the neural stem cell's own
receptors so we get more neurons there
but then also feed forward onto the host
and get more neurons there so we did
that we did that in that same stroke
like leion is a little complex for me to
do without a pointer but the red are the
stem cells the blue are all the neurons
and what we simply showed is that we got
lots and lots of neurons so the donor
cells became many many kinds of nms and
that's what all those orange and yellow
cells are donor red cells standing for
the green new end becoming lots and lots
of neons many more than just the the
normal amount of 3 to 5%
80% and I'll come back to whether that
was a smart thing at all and and they
went on and they had the right kind of
neural transmitters but what the arrow
shows is not only did we get more donor
derived neurons but in the oval you can
see more host derive neurons too the
anre working on the host stem cells now
initially we thought that this was great
and it was but do you really want 80%
more that's too
many the re the right ratio is only
about 3 to 5% now this animal did okay
did not have seizures but I think we
dodged the bullet here and it wasn't so
smart another example of where it wasn't
so smart is Illustrated over here we
went into the spinal cord with exactly
that those same kind of cells remember I
mentioned in the ALS model that the stem
cell the native stem cell putting it in
there that's gives us lots of motor
nurve if we put in the neural stem cell
that was now making more
N3 we started getting fewer motor
neurons fewer chat positive cells now it
wasn't that we were getting fewer
neurons we were getting lots of neurons
we were getting the wrong kind of NE now
what shows over here we are getting lots
of
sensory Sensory neurons could underly
alidia or pain this is not what we want
so what we were doing in fact is playing
with one system trying to give us more
neurons with NT3 was making us as you
can see lose all of our gdnf which was
doing something equally as good
so it taught us a lesson that playing
with one pathway can have unintended
consequences on another beneficial
pathway which says that sometimes it's
not smart to mock around with Mother
Nature
so is there a situation however where
you could put in a
transgend and that in fact is
Illustrated over here that there are
situations where you a want to deliver a
stem cell and all you want it to do is
to deliver a trans Gene in a global
fashion that's with brain tumors brain
tumors are very migratory they elude the
best surgeon Gene therapist radio
therapist that exists because the cells
break off and create these other
satellites that's why brain tumors are
so incured well we wondered if we armed
the stencil with a tumor killing Gene it
could find those satellites deliver the
tumor killing Gene and eradicate them
and there we didn't care what the stem
cell became it didn't even have to exist
as and persist as long as it didn't
cause any
Mischief those experiments were
something that Karen aboody was a post
talk in the lab started exploring taking
advantage of this path tropism to
deliver in fact it works we use GBM or
tumors as our example of showing that
this exact happens even in the adult
brain the intact adult brain very little
migration the injured or abnormal adult
brain different situation the whole
Terin is different that's what she
showed brain tumors were the
example this is now been replicated by
many other lab GES and Cancers and is in
fact giving rise to an FDA approved
clinical trial Now using stem cells to
deliver anal genes to G blastoma
but taking advantage of a fundamental
program of the stem cell which is a
pathet tropus in this case we would call
an
ARR as Illustrated over here you can you
can image the stem cell even if it's on
the opposite side of a tumor homing in
on the
tumor that if you stick it into the
tumor it will go to the edge of the
tumor and stop right at the interface of
the
tumor see right stop right at the
interface of the tumor uh and the normal
tissue except where a stem cell is
moving in and invading um invading
normal tissue and it'll take the tumor
and diminish it to about 80% of the size
you can stick the stem cell even into
the vascular system and if you have
metastatic cancer to the brain it will
home to the brain here's an example of
metastatic breast cancer again the stem
cell only in a situation where there's
metastases of the brain finding as you
can see here so here are the the
potential actions of a stem cell in
neurologic conditions I know I'm going
over my time I'm almost finished and I'm
going to try to wind up with some
important take that I think are
important these are the mechanisms that
I think the Sten you can see most of
them are inherent to Stem Cell Biology
and do not involve nor stem cell
replacement
will we get to mural stenc cell
replacement yes we will as we will get
to Heart replacement and all that but
we're just not there yet so but that
does not mean that we're incapacitated
and taking advantage of its biology for
translational so when do we actually get
here well we're starting to get some
clinical trials mostly taking advantage
of the
Sha the biggest obstacle to date so far
has been how do we exploit stem Cil
biology and I'm listing here all the
things that we do not know but the
biggest thing we do not know for most
diseases is what actually needs
fixing so we can have the best stem cell
that exists but if we don't know what it
is that needs to be fixed we don't know
what to deliver or when to deliver so
those who study the disease have to make
progress hand inand with we who work in
the
Sten the other major challenge to the
field is how to deal with chronic injury
everything that I or any other stencil
biologist has shown you to date
involves chronic involves acute fresh
spinal cord injury or any kind of CNS
injury but most of our patients have
chronic CN they've been in wheelchairs
for years which means that
it and and all the biology that I've
been telling you really happens in the
acute
environment so that's Illustrated over
here oh
sorry I guess in under the parabola is
where all the activity is but not only
is that window of opportunity lost when
you get to the chronic injury but also
whole other things of interpos cell
there's at and scarring and disruption
of connections and Vascular
Supply uh so it's going to take a whole
other Paradigm not just
using pre-existing strategies let's
illustrate it over here that if you take
the exact same Sten Cil and you expose
it to uh to to an injured environment in
a dish and the only difference is
whether the tissue that's damaged was
acutely injured or chronically injured
and then you do a differential display
what you can see using the sys of
reporter cell that it sees different
things it acts in different ways with
the acute injury there's an upregulation
of genes that mediate migration and
proliferation and differentiation in
antiapoptosis like the accelerate if you
expose it to tissue that was injured in
the remote past it down regulates all of
those genes and up regulates genes that
inhibit migration inhibit cration
inhibit differentiation or Pro aop so
the cells see something different so
maybe one thing is to try to recreate in
The Chronic injury the window of
opportunity that existed with the acute
that's one mechanism but again it's
going to take whole different kinds of
paradigms as you can see over here
different par paradigms where you
actually do real reconstruction and the
each time I won't be able to go through
that but this is the same stuff that I
showed you later earlier on about our
spinal CR injury where we actually use
biomaterials to create other ways of
getting through the spinal to the muscle
around the engine reconstructing
C and here is an example of stem cells
and biom materials and scaffold and you
require them together
the lesson is that it's always going to
be better to protect what you have and
trying to recreate the kind of
complexity that exists as a result of
normal
development what are the best cells to
use well this makes for a huge almost
ttic debate in the spin cell circuit
here are various ways for example to get
to the neural stem cell they all have
their clothes and their conss as you can
see here those on the right um locked in
to the neur ectoderm you're not going to
get tumors you're not going to get
inappropriate cell types but they don't
proliferate as much the cells on the
left very prolif easy to scale up but
they need to be tamed the chromatin is
not as compacted and you can get tumors
and you can get inappropriate Subs as
you can
see and here's a paper from Steve golden
where in the Parkinson's anal even after
he got good therapeutic
out some th positive cells after the
esm you didn't get katonis it wasn't
poorly differentiated cells that get
that that he also saw he started seeing
primitive neurectodermal tumor so
neoderm that just wasn't mature enough
so that's if you want to use non
neuroses and there's a lot of people in
the audience went now who want to think
about doing that from heart or the
nervous system just
remember these are not going to give
rise to Heart cells they're not going to
give rise to M they you're doing it
because you're trying to harness their
molecular
water but always remember that the stem
cell is still going to follow its
biological imperative you may be taking
it out of its environment and putting it
somewhere else it does not know that and
it is still going to follow its biologic
programs and here's an example of where
this investigator in his bottom paper
took mesenchimal stem cells and put it
into a model of multiple sclerosis which
is a very inflammatory disease the mezan
St cell simply saw the inflammation and
it started to proliferate prolif
and it just made a mess it was just
following its normal
imperative so
remember one of the cautions of putting
a cell where it doesn't normally belong
is understand what its biology is so you
may need to pick cells based on the
disease based on the action based on the
biologic
program that will play out its normal
biologic program in both a safe and
effective way
you may need to do this empirically but
the goal is always going to be that you
want to find something that restores
homeostasis and this simply kind of
recapitulates all of the actions that
I've shown you
today
so
circumspection does not mean a retreat
from home cautioning you to be
circumspect ises not mean this is
actually a quote for me does not mean
that this is not going to be promising
means that one needs to be so in
conclusion and I know I've gone over I
apologize for that I guess I didn't know
the technology as well as I wanted to
here are the various summaries that you
should take away that ultimately stem
cells are models of Developmental
programs that reimo these developmental
programs particularly those that are
homeostasis promoting but underly
plasticity and adaptation
are the ones you want to re invok
whether it's exogenous or
endogenous multiple mechanisms multiple
cell types engaging cross talk is what
we need
Toom to be Progressive of and
reinot it's better to work in concert
with these programs than working at
Cross purposes to them or bending the
program to be the way you think it
should be try to understand what it is
and then harness it th in an INT ENT
rational kind of way molecular therapies
are going to be the lwh hanging fruit
more so than trying to get the
particular cell type that you want we're
still involved in a huge amount of
intellectual heavy lifting to get there
which means looking how the cell type
got to be there to begin with plus even
trying to understand what cell type you
want to
repia autism even ALS there we were
mistaken we thought we just wanted to
replace mod Wars we were wrong we
as disease and the dish technology
that's also the low hanging food the
drug is into the patient then
recognizing that inflammation as a as a
Janus there's a late relationship
between inflammation and the stem cell
the stem on homes to where there's
pathology then it is becomes
anti-inflammatory but inflammation also
does harm remember the pediat Pediatric
age group I think I showed you that time
and time and and time again we started
off understanding the stenor biology by
looking at models of pediatric disease
and moving up to the adult so it wasn't
triple down it was Bubble Up um because
stem cells ultimately are developmental
biology the kids are developmental
biology cing themselves out and that
chronic established injury is still the
major major challenge for regenerative
medicine we have no we are nowhere near
to approaching the patients who in fact
are our largest
constituents so these are the people
that I need to thank and I'll be glad to
take any questions with whatever times
sorry I went over but I'm happy
to so I guess uh
do you talk to me or do I just look for
the Q&A
gu oh okay
so oh
okay okay that's great so question
number one is does it work for
Alzheimer's disease the answer is we
don't know there are people that are
trying Alzheimer's disease trying it
with Alzheimer's disease
based not on replacing cell types
because we don't know what kind of cell
type to replace but if Alzheimer's is
inflammatory maybe we can restore
inflammation uh damp down the
inflammation if there's certain trophic
factors that might be useful like bdnf
or
ngf either taking the amount of
neurotropic factors that are
intrinsically made by the neuro stem
cell or getting the neural stem cell to
make more of it has also being tried it
has not being tried in patients yet
it has had in animal models has not
really had the effect that we like
um the next question is does the death
cell program still work with these new
cells they you know they die if they
don't make connections they die if
they're crowded out um however if
there's a niche they will
integrate and they seem it's very
interesting add something to your
question host cells died because of
inflammation or oxidative stress or
toxins it's interesting that the neural
stem cell maybe because they're young
seem to be more resistant to metabolic
toxins oxidative stress to excited
toxicity so they actually can
survive even when some of the host cells
maybe because the hom cells have a
genetic flaw do die what happens with
the next question is
what happens with the bloodb brain
barrier for brain tumors well the bloodb
brain barrier seems to be compromised by
brain tumors anyway and that may be one
of the mechanisms by which the stem cell
can make it through the vascular
compartment into the pathology but it
also does it through another mechanism
the stem cell does seem to be able to
make it through the vascular the blood
brain barrier by squeezing through by
various kinds of mechanisms some of the
integrins and things like that also it
seems to just have its own biology that
allows it to go through in a way that
chattic cells do
not what is the impact of the pH in your
experiment we've not looked at that I'm
wondering whether you're uh talking
about these stat cells these cells that
become reprogrammed because of a very
acidic environment we do not see an
effect in PH other than to kill the
cells that to whole area of acidic
reprogramming as you might know is
coming under debate and it's unclear
whether it's a real
phenomenal does do stem
cells can stem cells repair damage made
to pereral nerves by chemotherapy on
individuals actually there are a lot of
people investigating that and the quick
early answer is we think that they can
but it needs to be explored more it it
still doesn't do it well enough can Sten
cells help with pulmonary
fibrosis that's a
hypothesis that's being explored in fact
it was just a paper that came out in the
Pediatric literature trying to use
mesenchimal stem cells to inhibit the
scarring that you see in the lung
disease that premature babies develop
that looked a bit promising now that may
happen just through condition medium it
may happen through the anti-inflam
flammatory anti-scarring effects of the
stem cells it's a very attractive
hypothesis we think it might work to
some extent things never work as clean's
life but that that is a
hope um well the next question
is well the rest are not questions oh
okay um in your in my opinion which
pring which reprogramming strategies
would be more suitable for clinical
translation um I would go with
non-integrating technique for right now
I would use episomal reprogramming mini
Loops that do not invol a v involve a
virus do not involve um integration
things may change if the small molecules
become better if the proteins become
better if the micro rnas become better
maybe that will change my mind right now
and we would love to be participate in
um chling IPS the technique we're going
with because it seems to be safest most
efficient cheapest easiest and most
scalable is episomal repl so that's
where we're going right now on this
particular day this particular year this
particular CL I'm going
go I think I've run through all the
questions can
um I can take some more I think I have
about a minute now or maybe I have
time
um okay I guess if there's no other
questions
um should I should
I I think all right I'm supposed to say
that's a rra so I apologize for some of
the technical snapo I apologize for
going over thank you very very much for
listening and for being so patient with
me hopefully I'll be invited back to
give you disease the indidual disease in
a dish thank you
byebye what do I do now Tracy